-I saw you in Brooklyn,
by the way,
performing your concert,
and I was --
-"Madame X."
-Mm-hmm.
-It was unbelievable.
-Thank you.
-And I -- What I loved about it
was that you chose
these smaller arenas.
You always do stuff
that no one´s doing.
You zig when people are zagging.
-Right.
-[ Laughter ]
-And then, people --
You can quote me on that.
And -- But here´s what I was
going to ask you. Do you --
-Did I make any money?
-[ Chuckles ] No.
No, I wasn´t going
to ask you that.
-I didn´t. [ Laughing ]
-I was going to ask you...
When people take your ideas --
you do all these things first.
-Mm-hmm.
-And then people take your ideas
and they don´t give you credit,
and I go,
"No, Madonna did that already."
-Yeah, and they also
don´t do it as good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean...
-That´s -- [ Laughs ]
That´s exactly right.
-That sounds really,
um, arrogant...
-Yeah.
-...but it´s kind of true.
-No.
-Yeah.
-"Madame X."
This is on Paramount+ tomorrow.
What -- What do you hope
people take away from this,
from watching this documentary?
-Um, that art is important
in our lives.
I don´t think people
emphasize that enough.
-Yeah.
-I -- I´m really inspired
by James Baldwin, the writer.
-Yeah.
-Have you heard of him?
-Of course.
-Don´t lie.
-I have heard of James Baldwin.
-Okay, yeah.
He was a great source of
inspiration for me growing up,
and he was a great source
of inspiration for the show.
And one of the things I quote
over and over again in the show
is that artists are here
to disturb the peace.
And so --
-Wow.
-And so I hope
that I have disturbed
not only your peace
this afternoon but...
-You always disturb my peace.
-...people´s peace
while they watch the show,
but I mean that in the best way.
-No, yeah.
You get in good trouble.
-Good trouble.
-Yeah, you really do.
No, no, no!
Now, why would you --
Madonna. Madonna!
[ Sultry R&B music plays ]
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
Stop it.
Oh, my heavens.
Stop it. Stop it.
I don´t know what to do.
Stop it right now.
Absolutely -- This is --
♫♫
-No one´s gonna see anything.
My God.
-Sorry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh.
Every -- Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
I don´t know what --
I don´t what to --
-Because life is not just
about interviewing kiddies.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
-Is that right?
-Don´t you want
to talk to an adult?
-Is that right? Yeah.
-Let´s have some
adult conversation.
-Are you talking to an adult
right now?
-I´m not sure.
[ Laughter ]
I´m talking to someone who´s --
I feel, like, you´re --
You´re in some kind of conflict
right now.
-Oh, interesting.
-Yeah, have you been
to a therapist?
-I went a --
I went once or twice.
I didn´t --
It wasn´t my thing.
-No.
-Do you go to therapy?
-Um, I just -- I write.
[ Laughter ]
I write.
-So -- So, no?
-It´s a form of therapy.
No, I write, and I also hope
that I have good friends,
and I talk my [bleep] out
with people and, you know,
that´s a kind of therapy,
don´t you think?
-I can be your friend.
-You think?
-Yeah. You should call me.
-You should´ve --
You know,
you came over to my house once.
-I did. I had a great time.
You introduced me to "Ladybug."
Um, whatever it´s called.
"Miraculous."
I didn´t know what that was.
-Do your kids watch it?
-Now, because of you.
-Okay.
-I do everything because of you.
Oh, my gosh.
Is this like --
See? This is why
I don´t go to therapy.
It gets -- It gets --
It gets nowhere.
-You get --
Yep, and it´s gonna --
Just talk to me.
-Do you smoke?
-No.
-Me neither.
-I don´t.
I smoke for photo shoots.
-But you never smoked?
-No.
-Because of your voice?
-Yeah, I just don´t like it.
-Yeah, me neither. Do you vape?
-I´d rather...
I like...opiates.
[ Laughter ]
-Ridiculous.
I want to show a clip.
Here is Madonna in "Madame X."
Take a look at this.
♫♫
-♫ It´s not gypsy blood ♫
♫ We live between
life and death ♫
♫♫
♫ Waiting to move on ♫
♫ And in the end ♫
♫ We accept it ♫
♫♫
♫ We shake hands with our fate ♫
♫ And we walk past ♫
♫ There´s no rest for us
in this world ♫
♫♫
♫ Finally a lost love ♫
-Yes! That´s what
I´m talking about!
Everybody, Madonna is here!
Madonna!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was trying to think
of a question to ask you
that´s never been asked.
-Good luck.
-I know.
How about this one?
Ready for this?
-Yeah.
-This might be the best question
I´ve ever asked.
-Okay.
-Has any review of anything
you´ve done gotten it right?
Is that a good question?
-I mean, occasionally.
It´s rare.
-So they don´t, really.
-In the 40 years that I´ve been
doing what I´ve been doing --
-40 years?
-40 years. Can you believe it?
-No. That´s insane.
-It is. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you know who you are?
Do you even know who you are?
You are Madonna. Oh, my God.
-I still don´t even know
who I am.
-Yeah, you really are
unbelievable.
I mean, the first single
was what? "Everybody?"
-Mm-hmm.
-And do you remember
anything about that?
Like, what would you do to --
Do you remember
hearing yourself on the radio,
and going, "Wow"?
-I remember I was living
on the Upper West Side,
on 99th and Riverside Drive,
and was just broke
and wondering if things were
ever going to work out for me.
And I had signed my record deal.
And I was told that
they were going to start
playing my song on the radio,
"Everybody."
-Yeah.
-And then, suddenly,
my roommate had her radio on
down the hall, and I heard it
drifting down the hallway.
And I was like,
"Wait, what is that?
What is that?"
And I ran down the hall,
and she´s like,
"They´re playing your song
on the radio.
And I just stood there
like, "Wow!
It happened. It works."
It was like magic.
-Yeah.
-It was the most amazing moment.
-Is this going to be in this --
I heard there´s a rumor that --
-A visual autobiography?
-Yes, of course.
-Don´t call it a biopic.
-But, yeah, --
I would never call it a biopic.
-How dare you?
-No, how dare you?
I think it´s cool.
Once again, no one´s done this.
-Well, the reason I´m doing it
is because a bunch of people
have tried to write
movies about me,
but they´re always men.
Ugh!
-Wait. What do you mean?
What are you talking about?
[ Cheers and applause ]
No.
Men are good.
Some men.
-Some men are good.
-Yeah.
-Men -- "Good men" is pretty
much an oxymoron, but --
-Oh, my gosh.
-Anyways...
No, because people
were writing --
I read Universal was doing a --
Like, they sent me the script
because they wanted my blessing.
And I read it,
and it was the most hideous,
superficial crap I ever read.
And then I found out
that some --
I found out --
I´m not even gonna say his name,
but he´s a total misogynist
was directing.
And I´m thinking,
"Why would these people
make a movie about my life?"
There´s nothing true
in the script.
The guy who is making it has
no understanding of women,
no appreciation of women,
no respect for women.
So, like, this happened
a couple of times,
and I had to, like,
call people up,
call up the heads of studios,
call up my agents
and threaten them
and say that I will, like,
stand in front of the building
and make -- and protest
and make everybody´s life
a misery if
they go through with it.
And they still did not
take me seriously.
So, finally, I just threw
down the gauntlet.
Have you ever thrown down
the gauntlet?
-I´ve thought about it.
-Therein lies the rub.
You have to throw down
the gauntlet.
-"Therein lies the rub."
Yeah, I did.
-You have to do this.
You have to do this.
-Oh, look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay? Never mind.
I´ll pick it up myself.
-Yeah, exactly.
"I´ll pick it up myself."
-Because that´s what
you´ve got to do in life.
You´ve got to
pick it up yourself.
Anyways, no, I just said,
"You know what?
There´s nobody on this planet
that can write or direct
and make a movie about me
better than me."
And that is just the truth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I agree.
I love that you´re doing that.
And, honestly, no one has -- -
-Keep talking while
I undo my glove.
-Yeah, no problem. Yeah.
-Say interesting things, please.
-I have an interesting thing
to say.
These are myths and rumors
about you,
and I want to know
if some things
are true
and some things are false.
Do you mind me going through
these and you tell me?
-Go ahead.
-Well, do I believe you?
Will you tell me the truth?
[ Laughs ]
Honestly, I can´t even tell you
how nervous I feel right now.
You just -- You do -- You make
me so -- you make me so --
-♫ Good inside ♫
-Yeah, you really do.
Okay.
-Come on, you guys. Like a...
-♫ Virgin ♫
-Oh, my God.
-♫ Touched for the... ♫
-♫ Very first time ♫
-♫ Like a...♫
-♫ Virgin ♫
-♫ When your heart beats ♫
♫ Next to mine ♫
-Come on, now.
That´s what -- Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
An impromptu...
That´s what I´m talking about.
Alright. Wait, wait, wait!
-Trying to get my --
-Alright, ready?
These are myths
and rumors about you,
and it may or may not be true.
Your first job was
at Dunkin´ Donuts,
and you were fired.
-Yeah.
It was one of the first jobs
I had working
when I moved to Manhattan.
And I did get fired
because I was
playing with the jelly squirter.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, alright.
-Have you ever seen
a jelly squirter?
-No, no, no, I haven´t.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
No, stop, stop, stop.
Okay, here we go.
Just stop, stop, stop.
Alright, here we go.
-It´s funny how everything
is a sexual innuendo.
-It really is.
How about this?
"Vogue" was originally
only going to be a B-side
because it wasn´t considered
strong enough
to be released as a single.
-Yeah, it´s true.
-What?
But "Vogue" is
the biggest song ever.
It was the B-side?
What was the A-side?
-Well, there´s a lot
of unenlightened people
in the world.
-Yeah.
-They can´t see into the future.
-Did you write "Jimmy Jimmy"
thinking of me?
-Nope.
-Okay.
-Here´s a myth or a rumor.
You turned down
the role of Catwoman
in the film "Batman Returns,"
and the lead in "Showgirls"
you turned down.
Did you ever see those movies?
And what did you think of them?
-I saw them both.
And I was -- I regret that
I turned down Catwoman.
That was pretty fierce.
-Oh, really?
-"Showgirls," no.
But I also turned down
the role in "The Matrix."
Can you believe that?
-You did?
-I wanted to kill myself.
-Oh, stop it. You´re Madonna.
-That´s like one
the best movies ever made.
-You don´t regret anything.
Look at you.
-A teeny, tiny part
of me regrets
that just one moment in my life.
-Madonna, are...
Wow. You´re unbelievable.
Why? Why?
But why are you such
a troublemaker?
Why? Just stop.
-Because.
Because artists are just here
to disturb the peace.
-Just stop.
Just be good.
-Okay, okay. I´m sorry.
-Behave!
-I will.
-Please behave!
-Okay!
-Madonna, I can´t even tell
you -- I really do mean this.
I´m just -- I love you, and I´m
honored to have you here.
And I just love you.
You´re one in a million.
I´m about to perform --
I´m about to perform
some "Kid Theater"
but first,
I need an acting partner,
and I couldn´t ask
for a better one.
She´s a legendary pop icon
and music superstar.
Please welcome the one,
the only Madame X.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♫ Kid Theater ♫
♫ Kid Theater! ♫
-Are you kidding?
I bow. I bow!
I bow down to the queen.
-Permission to stand up.
-I love you.
-Do you?
-Yes.
That´s exactly right.
That´s exactly right!
Alright!
Welcome to the show.
Madame X,
thank you for doing this.
-Thank you for having me.
-You have a new movie out
tomorrow on Paramount+
called "Madame X,"
and I thought it would be fun
to preview some scenes
for our audience
by acting them out together,
but here´s the catch.
The scenes we´ll be reading
are not from the actual film.
Instead, they are written
by elementary school kids.
-Which is why I´m wearing
an elementary school dress.
-Yes, of course. No, I know.
Of course. I got it. I got it.
I totally got it.
We gave the kids no direction.
We just said "Madame X."
That´s all we told them
and let them do the rest.
So, it´s time for "Kid Theater."
Here we go.
-♫ Kid Theater ♫
♫ Kid Theater ♫
-This first one from Jess.
She´s 7 years old.
"Madame X."
She´ll be playing
the role of Madame X.
I´ll be playing
the role of Denny.
Higgins will read
the scene description.
Higgins, set up the scene,
please.
-Oh.
-Sorry.
-Oh [bleep].
-No, wait. No.
[ Laughter ]
That´s not in the script.
That´s not in the script at all.
-That´s not --
-I know,
but I´m holding two
ice cream cones.
-It´s, um...
-Oh, this one here.
-Well...
-This is so silly.
-Come on, baby.
[ Laughter ]
-Hurry up, it´s melting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This dance you´re doing
right now,
it´s too slow.
-Mm-hmm.
-Chin?
-Chin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Yes, you do.
Don´t talk back to me.
-[ Laughs ]
That´s not in the script at all!
-[ Chuckles ]
-That´s in the script.
-Yeah, it is, actually, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A-A-Alright.
Alright! Hold on!
Hold on! Hold on!
Alright! Alright!
Hold on now.
Alright. Very good.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright. Okay.
[ Laughs ]
-I´m not done with my dance.
You´re censoring me.
-No, I´m not. Never.
I would never.
♫♫
No, alright! Alright!
Alright! Okay! Okay!
This is -- Alright.
Higgins, whose line is it?
whose line is it? Okay!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-It´s your line!
"Madame XXX."
-Alright. Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-It´s melted.
Here, lick my hand.
-[ Laughs ]
-Just a litt--
-And scene!
Alright.
That was great.
Alright, here we go.
Let´s do --
Alright, that´s one.
Alright, let´s go.
Let´s do another one.
This was sent by Theodore.
This stars two characters --
Madame X and...
Stupid Fox.
[ Laughter ]
-Let´s guess.
-Do I play Ma--
[ Both laugh ]
-Okay. Here we go.
Higgins, set it up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks for the support.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That´s kind of good.
-Not bad?
-Not bad, actually.
-Thank you.
-That´s kind of --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-Alright. Alright.
And scene!
[ Cheers and applause ]